from the german
wehrmacht the photos suddenly show soldiers that
we know as nazi warriors suddenly
from a side that you would never have
expected so suddenly it’s
a certain because i don’t have any
sentimentality they suddenly come
as people with longing hence martin
dammann blob’s private photo  albums from
various war
[music]
the publisher rockstar there are photos like
this in all photo albums from war hat,
crazy enough, there are a lot of these fodder in the
german colors from the second
world war
[music]
i think the situation of the
soldiers themselves was also special
they were then
sometimes years further away than they
could have dreamed of coming here and were
therefore particularly isolated
maybe the need for a
temporary escape from the counties was greater
than elsewhere
the wehrmacht
you can’t prove anything
i can only guess but then
i would think that these performers are
both gay and auc  h
heterosexuals were
there is a nice term from a
sociologist the head one who thought
that the actual life has the
ideology under living so to speak
it is that on the one hand there was
this ideological have but
that life itself in turn had its
own things  searched and i think
more clearly in the direction that he
actually assumes any information that remains and i
actually also believe that after
the many years that we have been dealing with the in the
third reich
that it might now be possible
can also show such difficult topics
in with diamonds and with an
ambivalence i very much hope that it will
not be understood like that and because i was
it i want to show i am that i am
the
war and and s&t put crimes into
perspective
i don’t want that
[music]